one of the few Sports from perhaps known
all around the world just by a single
name of Pele and someone who really
transcended his sport and also helped to
be part of the game through its period
of growth through the period from black
and white to color through the
commercialization of the game and he
himself was the figure who so many knew
a towering figure not just in football
but in Brazil and Brazilian society as
well and the fact is he is the only
person to have won the World Cup three
times and what a debut it was for him at
the World Cup in 1958 just 17 years old
he carried them to Victory and although
injuries then curtailed his involvement
in 1962 he was still there at the start
of the tournament when Brazil won yet
again defended their title and he was
determined to return to the World Cup to
play a huge part himself and that came
in 1970 when he won the World Cup
scoring in the final in the victory over
Italy in Mexico and really he
established himself as one of the greats
of all time spending his career largely
in Brazil at Santos perhaps that's
something that's very different in this
era as well where we see Talent leaving
Brazil and other South American nations
to play in Europe something Palais
didn't do but he really helped to still
make a name for himself and his presence
on the global sporting stage had been
there in the decades after he'd
continued playing he was a regular sort
of fixture around sporting events and on
the sidelines of those and very involved
in commercial deals as well and that
meant he was always there always around
as an ambassador for the sport and for
the country
and Robert should just say that um
pele's death has been confirmed Now by
his daughter on
Instagram and uh you look you were at
the World Cup I gather that Pele was
able to see a few of the the games uh
that were played at that um
uh extraordinary uh World Cup the Brazil
team of course parading that Banner
um in one of the games uh Killian mbappe
tweeting pray for the king during uh the
World Cup yeah the World Cup there was
this a small fan Zone area for common
ball the South American governing body
and there there was this almost
life-size Recreation of Pele there and
people were there standing taking their
pictures next to him we did some live
broadcasting actually from around there
as we were sort of speaking to fans and
he really was obviously talked about a
lot during this World Cup in Qatar
because of the growing concerns about
his health and we had various players
like Harry Kane being asked about his
well-being because pele's Health had
been in Decline for some years and that
had obviously created a lot of concern
from across the game and yet there he
was uh posting on Instagram at the
moment the final in Qatar less than two
weeks ago when Messi finally won a World
Cup in each talked about how football
continues to tell its story as always an
enthralling way that's what Pele said on
Instagram and he was talking about what
a gift it was to watch this spectacle to
the future of our Sport and really he
was sort of seeing the future of the
sport in in strong hands and he was in
hospital at the time in Sao Paulo as
those concerns were growing about his
health but he was very much talking
about the ongoing uh and current state
of the game and the generation still uh
playing their role and obviously Messi
finally winning a World Cup did create
new debate about who perhaps is the
greatest of all time him or Diego
Maradona his fellow Argentine and of
course for many it was a Pele who stands
above the rest of them as being the the
greatest of all time
yes well as you say the names were
bandied around weren't they at the uh
World Cup largely because of the Messi
Ronaldo uh thing but Maradona obviously
mentioned as well but certainly
Rob Brazilians will have no doubt at all
about who was the uh the greatest and
that would be their Pele
absolutely for Brazilians really he was
the figure who delivered the three World
Cups for Brazil really competes on the
world stage is the symbol of scorching
achievement with the the yellow Jersey
the famous yellow Jersey that Pele
really made his own it's where they do
project themselves sporting wise on the
world stage it's why uh at the Olympics
in Rio in 2016 football isn't perhaps
always the biggest of sports F in the
Olympics in the men's game but certainly
it was in Brazil and perhaps that's
largely due to the role that Pele
himself has played and the fact we see
future generations of stars someone like
Neymar now they are all living in his
shadow so many players are living in his
shadow and Palais also really helped to
reach audiences Beyond uh football
traditional football heartlands as well
particularly in North America in the
United States Pele was one of those
players who was sort of widely known
featuring sort of in in in in
non-sporting context too and all around
the world even if you weren't someone
who was perhaps necessarily a fan of the
game always the Pele really was the
figure who helped to stand out above
them all and and it's because of his
Elegance his grace on the pitches his
goals and obviously his scoring record
is
debated how many goals are actually
counted in terms of his how many he did
score for in his career where it was
over a thousand or how many are counted
but certainly it's his goals and his uh
and his success on the pitch really the
fact we see so much of it televised
which Generations in the decades
beforehand that it wasn't captured on
camera as much but certainly we see a
lot of pele's achievements captured in
that way forevermore and they do provide
that lasting Legacy and Pele really
helping to grow the game into the true
Global sport that that it is today we
saw that during the World Cup certainly
yeah in Qatar in recent weeks and he
really has been the sort of the standard
bearer of what we do know as the global
sport the beautiful game for so many